vor allem pennsylvania einer der ort auf
denen jetzt eigentlich die ganze welt
schaut denn dort kann sich das alles
entscheiden
ein battleground state wie die
amerikaner den ort nennen und auch ein
ort an dem jetzt immer mehr menschen auf
die straßen gehen um zu zeigen für wen
sie sind und das nicht immer friedlich
umsatz chefreporter maximilian kiewel
ist für uns in pennsylvania und erzählt
uns was da jetzt für eine stimmung in
der luft liegt hallo guten morgen aus
philadelphia wo auch drei tage nach der
us wahl immer noch nicht klar ist wer
das land in zukunft regieren wird aber
hier in diesem wichtigen staaten zu
wählen ja macht sich langsam auf den
sitzen reißt und zwar optimismus unter
den anhängern von joe biden
sie tanzen sie jubeln werden laut musik
weil sie glauben dass am ende so beiden
auch hier im fenster wenn ja die nötigen
stimmen holen wird und am ende der
nächste präsident der vereinigten
staaten zu werden
das alles werden wir heute den tag über
im blick behalten hier in philadelphia
für bild leiten
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich jedes nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren